one of my favorite things kevin nealon
did uh on the talk show and all the
writers loved this is that he and i are
talking he's doing really well he's
killing and then there was just a little
lull
and um
you and neelan are very self-conscious
of a lull like oh oh there's a lull
something has to happen and so you know
you'll always come up with something or
say like you know you'll do some shtick
because you can't have the silence
so then it just gets quiet just for a
fraction of a second and neil neil and
went
where is our waiter
i know i know
kevin has the best driest throwaways
of anybody i think and i i'm i'm a
dancing puppy i i i have to have laughs
and i have to kill or i think i'll be
dismissed i have to repeat this um there
was that disease there was kind of a
there was kind of a christmas there was
a private uh i i don't i don't think i
mean there may have been cameras there
but i don't think it's going to be
repeated or anything but it was part of
the netflix comedy festival mm-hmm and
um they asked me to host this thing for
nor mcdonald and a bunch of people spoke
and everyone was saying really great
stuff and a lot of people were funny but
man kevin ewan had the greatest line
because we were a lot of us were talking
about how brave norm was and he really
was he was fearless as a comedian yeah
and then uh kevin newman gets up and he
says you know he's saying very funny
things and he just says you know
um a lot of people up here are talking
about how norm mcdonald was uh
was brave in his comedy uh
i think of it more as a lack of judgment
i was just like oh my god that is
that was the best line of the night yeah
just uh just bad judgment i think uh
norm had that gear of not caring or
wanting like he would walk rooms i know
larry bubbles brown a friend of mine
from north norm worked a bit and uh he
would he could clear the room san jose
improv like at least 300 people slowly
walked out
so it's bravery or or whatever i i
worked with him at the comedy store once
it was just one of those nights bill
burr was there was just he just said the
word [ __ ] like
200 times
right this guy's got a [ __ ] right and a
cat he just knew how funny it was to say
that over and over and over so of course
the comedians love that kind of comedian
we're all dying right but the audience
kind of where do we go with this and he
just went
there's only one norm
there was uh i mean i've probably
mentioned this before but
i always like i say that a lot i always
love it when and one of the first people
i saw do this live um was gilbert
godfrey who also sadly recently god rest
his soul which yeah i like to say that
yeah well he's a star now he's one up to
the stars well a good friend of mine
died and he was from brooklyn and he
always used to say that so my mother you
know really good friend my mother you
know god rest his soul my father
and i thought it was such a nice yeah
but if you're talking about historical
figures you can't
you can't say like so anyway george
washington god rest his soul his meeting
with my great
soul and then he turns to paul god rest
his soul
and uh then of course god rest his soul
you know i used to i thought satan
that's the only one that's the only one
you can talk about
satan [ __ ] that guy but anyway uh along
comes jimmy stewart god rest his soul
and the horse he rolled in on
god rest his soul if he had a horse